[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANDY WAITE: Hi everyone.
My name is Mandy Waite from
Developer Advocate for the
Google Cloud platform.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
FRED SAUER: Welcome indeed.
I'm Fred Sauer, also
Developer Advocate
on the Cloud platform.
Today we have a number of
questions that you've already
submitted that we
want to answer.
But first, Mandy, you have a
little presentation for us?
Kind of give some of the
viewers who are not as
familiar with App Engine an
overview, and then we'll get
right into your questions.
MANDY WAITE: Yes, so most people
who will be on the live
stream are actually people who
have signed up for the App
Engine startup pack.
So welcome to everybody.
Thanks for joining
the program.
Hopefully, this will inspire
you to use some
more of those credits.
We're going to look at some of
the features of App Engine in
this presentation that you may
have actually overlooked, you
may not have seen, or
may not be aware of.
So we are going to dive straight
into presentation.
Yeah, so we've done intros.
So firstly, the startup
value proposition.
App Engine is a great product,
but what's the
real value for startups?
So one of the key points--
and this kind of stuff is
already documented at
Cloud.google.com, but we were
going to make a big point of
these value proposition
statements here.
App Engine is very quick
to get started with.
It allows for very rapid
development of applications.
And that's important to startups
who want to build a
minimum viable product in
perhaps hours, not days like
they used to.
They want to get their
application out to market as
quickly as possible.
And to facilitate that
Google App Engine is
extremely easy to use.
We give you all of the tools
you need to build your
applications, to test, to
launch, and then to update
your application's
going forward.
We also provide a very rich
set of APIs and services,
which you can build your
application upon, leveraging
things like mail, XMPP, and
other cast services in the
background.
Also, autoscale, people keep
talking about autoscale, when
I mention App Engine.
The media scalability almost to
most users of App Engine is
almost like there's infinite
scale, so you can scale
rapidly and as massively
as you need to.
And also one of the final points
is that you only have
to pay for what you use.
App Engine is free to use
to get started with.
You get some benefits from
sign-up for billing,
particularly the credit card,
so you guys are all already
signed up for billing, but you
only pay for the resources
that you use as your
application grows.
And here's some credit, some
people that have used App
Engine and been successful
with it.
So Khan Academy offer teaching
programs online.
And they're very pleased
with App Engine.
We use their statements quite
often, and these folks they
feel that App Engine gives them
the ability to spend all
of their time developing their
application and not worrying
about infrastructure.
Pulse in a very similar
position.
A quote from Greg Bayer there
that they could spend time not
worrying about the things
that they used to
have to worry about.
Google now takes care of
those things for them.
Just to go over very quickly of
some of the new features in
App Engine.
We update App Engine pretty
much every month, so we're
currently at 1.7.7.
And in case you're still lagging
behind a little bit,
it's important to keep
up-to-date with new updates.
And to look at some of the
features we've introduced
recently, in App Engine 1.7.5 we
introduced Cloud Endpoints
points, which we'll talk about
in more detail; Cloud
Messaging support, high
memory instances.
In 1.7.6, a bit of a lesser
release, but we introduced
Task queue Async Methods, and
if you're developing in
Python, we finally got a
multi-threaded development AppServer.
In 1.7.7, which was released
in April, that was last
release, we finally provided
Java 7 support.
it was previously available
in SDK.
SSL support for Python, Maven
support for Cloud Endpoints,
and also we removed the minimal
charge of $2.10.
So you no longer have to pay
anything until you actually
hit your quotas.
So just going to quickly go over
some of those features
that you may have actually
missed, that maybe not
actually be completely
apparent.
You may have started off with
App Engine a while back and
actually not kept up-to-date
with some of the features
we've introduced.
Cloud Endpoints is a really
important feature for us.
Basically, what it's allowed you
to do is to develop APIs
in a way that's very similar
to the way that Google
Developers their APIs.
You can take an existing
application or develop a new
application, and annotate your
classes and methods within the
application, to expose those
classes and methods as an API.
Once you've exposed them as an
API, you can discover that
API, there are various utilities
that we provide that
allow you to get discovery
documents and to build API
client libraries for
your own API.
With those libraries you can
then go on to build clients
for Chrome, for Web applications
in general, for
Android and for iOS.
So we thought that Cloud
Endpoints is an extremely
important feature.
So if you have interest
in building
particularly mobile backends--
I want to say backends by using
the broader sense of the
term, the way App
Engine uses it--
but if you're interested in
building mobile backends, then
you should really check out
Google Cloud Endpoints.
Another thing that people
sometimes miss is AppStats.
It's not turned on by default,
you can add it to your
application.
And you can use it for profile
in your OPC course.
You can basically use it
to work out where your
application is spending time.
App Engine Sockets.
This is a highly sought
after feature.
Previously in App Engine you
were not able to create
sockets of your own to create
outbound sockets.
We've introduced that feature.
It's enabled for trusted testers
at the moment, which
means you have to sign up for a
program and agree to do some
testing and feedback with
it, but it is available
for you to use today.
Also we provide a Search API.
And again some of these services
are experimental,
which means they are
liable to change.
Cloud Endpoints in currently
also experimental.
They are liable to change from
release to release, but
they're worth looking at now.
Search API is one
such feature.
And that allows you to do
Google-like search as across
your own application data.
It support things like custom
scoring, which is the ability
to create algorithms
that score and
results they've returned.
And also rich snippeting, which
allows you to return
HTML snippets of your search
results with the search term
highlighted in bold.
And also supports GeoSearch.
So if you've got the appropriate
data on your
application database,
then you can do
GeoSearch across your data.
And for those of you basically
in the European Union, and
there are several of you, many
of you, in fact, we also
support App Engine European
Data Centers.
So this is great for compliance
and locality of
reducing ping time
and suchlike.
You do have to sign up for paid
application for this, but
you guys are already signed
up for paid--
so that's great-- so you
can use that today.
Also, we have a fairly extensive
and growing all the
time Development Stack.
We have Maven support, we have
Maven archetypes and plug-ins
that you can use to deploy
your applications.
Jenkins is also supported in the
Cloud for a thing called
Cloud Base.
Online IDA called codenvy,
which is also
supported in App Engine.
And we also have the Google
plug-in for eclipse, which
ties into the SDK.
And very quickly looking into
the storage options.
Storage is a big thing for
application development.
We have many different
options.
And the ones we're not going to
go into detail today, but
you can look them up
online and get more
details about them.
But we have Unstructured data
support using Google Cloud
Storage and Google Drive;
Structured data--
The App Engine DataStore; and
also Relational data by using
Google Cloud SQL.
Very briefly covering
those three options.
I'm not going to actually
talk about Drive today.
Drive is a Cloud product, but we
don't generally talk about
it in these particular talks.
NoSQL DatsStore, so this is
the App Engine DataStore--
schemaless; it's for atomic
transactions and queries.
This is really great
for internet scale,
denormalizable DataSets.
So really think differently,
no joins when you're using
this kind of NoSQL DataStore.
And also a fairly standard
Cloud SQL [INAUDIBLE]
is really MySQL in the Cloud.
It's very familiar to anybody
who's used MySQL before.
It's fully managed and it's best
really for bounded scale.
We don't have high levels of
scale for Cloud SQL yet.
And I believe it's actually
out of experimental now.
And the final offering,
last but not least, is
Google Cloud Storage.
And this is really a bucket
for storing all types of
unstructured data.
The five things you really
want from a DataStore--
reliability, durability,
speed, low cost and
simplicity-- are all
encapsulated in
Google Cloud Storage.
So you can check those
options out online.
And just a quick mention of
Google I/O. Google I/O is
going to happen next week.
If you haven't got a ticket,
it's unfortunate, but you can
stream the events live.
You can follow up afterwards
on YouTube.
There's many interesting talks,
many talks on the Cloud
platform, including
the App Engine.
If you want to be more
involved, we
also have I/O extended.
And you can find out
more about that
from these links here.
These links will be available
on YouTube afterwards if you
need to go back have
a look at them.
So we really are going to
open up for questions.
And Fred and I are going to try
and bounce some questions
back and forth to one another.
FRED SAUER: This is
my favorite part.
MANDY WAITE: Your
favorite part?
FRED SAUER: I do.
MANDY WAITE: Is it?
But you're an App Engine expert,
and I'm kind of new to
App Engine.
I may struggle.
FRED SAUER: Well, listening to
the presentation, I think I
may dispute that.
[LAUGHTER]
FRED SAUER: Since you have spent
a lot of time talking
already, do maybe want to throw
a question at me and
start it that way?
MANDY WAITE: OK, yes.
So we opened up a moderator
page on the Google
Developer Live site.
So we have several questions
from there, we pulled some.
Well, we'll maybe also get a
chance to look at some of them
afterwards, but we
have like 20 old
questions we can go through.
FRED SAUER: OK
MANDY WAITE: So one of them, the
first one, was I want to
develop a restful web service
using Google App Engine that's
consumed by my web application
when in a different domain.
How do I restrict the calls only
to my web application?
What are the best practices?
FRED SAUER: OK.
So this is a question of cross
domain, or what the standards
like to refer to as cross-origin
requests.
So if you look on the W3C web
page, you'll find something
called CORS.
C-O-R-S and it stands for
cross-origin request source?
I forget the abbreviation,
I use it too much.
MANDY WAITE: Just call
it CORS, right?
FRED SAUER: Cross-origin request
sharing, I believe
what the actual abbreviation
is.
And basically, this is a
mechanism whereby servers and
browsers agree on how to
communicate the domain of the
website that is making a request
to the server, and
from the server to either grant
access to that content
or forbid it.
And what you do is when you set
up simple resources, like
even images in an image tag, or
when you make an XML HTTP
request, you can specify that
that request is a cross-origin
request-- so it's headed for a
domain other than the one that
the website's running on.
So maybe your website's on
mygreatapp.com and the Backend
service that you're connecting
to, an App Engine, is actually
on mygreatbackendservice.com.
And you can do that, but you
have to set this extra flag in
your HTML in your JavaScript
to make the
cross-origin request.
And then on the server, for a
get request there'll be an
extra HTTP header coming in
as the origin header.
And this is an indication to the
server that this request
came from another origin.
And right then you can make the
decision in your request
handler whether or not you want
to allow that request.
And you do that by sending
another response back, which
is the access control
cross-origin allow.
And you can specify the domains
that are allowed.
If you make a post request or
a put request, than the
browser will do something even
smarter than that; it will
send what's called the preflight
request, and will
send a request in advance and
get permission before it
actually does the submission.
So the short answer to this
question is are there existing
senders to do this?
It's very easy to do.
Just look up CORS, C-O-R-S, and
implement the details there.
And you can do that in your
request handler in your HTML
app, and you should
be good to go.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent, well.
You've got one for me, right?
FRED SAUER: I do I do.
MANDY WAITE: Is it
an easy one?
FRED SAUER: Hopefully.
Come up with a shorter answer
then than mine.
Maybe we should have started
with an easier one.
Let's see, so how viable or
recommended would it be to
build a back in service for
mobile apps around Google
Cloud Endpoints?
MANDY WAITE: All
right, OK, so.
I think really that's probably
the big use case for Cloud
Endpoints, built-in
mobile Backends.
And when we say Backends, again,
we're talking about the
general sense of it rather
than the App
Engine sense of Backends.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: If you want to
build an application that will
provide resources and services
that are consumed by mobile
devices, then Cloud Endpoints
will do that for
you out of the box.
I think pretty much we covered
most of that in the slides.
But the documentation is pretty
extensive, both for
Java and for Python.
So if you want to find out more
about how to use Cloud
Endpoints, you can
check that out.
And there was also Google I/O
Talk last year, wasn't there,
the one that was long?
FRED SAUER: There was, yes.
MANDY WAITE: So you can
actually get a lot of
information from looking at the
Google I/O sessions from
the previous years.
FRED SAUER: Very good.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah?
FRED SAUER: All right,
your turn.
MANDY WAITE: My turn?
OK, so last week--
maybe that was last week,
or it could have been
written last week.
Last week I had to rename an
entity-kind name for Google
App Engine Java.
I had to write one-time code in
my application to duplicate
each entity to the new kind
name, delete all entities,
then remove the one-time code,
and re-apply the application.
Is there an easier way
of doing this?
FRED SAUER: I think
this is a little
bit of a longer question.
But I think the person who asked
it is actually on the
right track and how
to do this.
So first, let me contrast this
with how you would do things
in a relational data world,
where you have a fixed schema
for your database.
So if you have, for example, a
table in a relational database
that's called customer.
And you decide, for whatever
reason, you want to
restructure that, and you want
to call it customer 2.
What you would actually have
to do is you would have to
declare a maintenance window,
you'd have to take the website
down, and you would then
perform the database
maintenance.
You would rename that table,
which locks the entire table
and all data in it.
You would modify the code in the
application server, you'd
bring everything back up.
And maybe half an hour later,
maybe a few hours later, you'd
be up and running.
And that was maybe acceptable
a number of years ago, when
website regularly went under
maintenance, and a lot of
systems were just 8 to 5.
But now we live in a world,
where everyone is connected to
the internet, it's always
5 o'clock somewhere.
Everyone needs to get to
your site all the time.
And so what you really want is
a system, where you can make
changes while the system's
up and running.
And part of the question
actually has the answer here
and how you do this.
So the specific question was,
how do I rename an entity?
But you can generalize the
question, what if you wanted
to add new required properties
to particular
entity in the DataStore?
Or you wanted to restructure,
you're going from three
separate entities and you're
combining them into this new
data structure, where you put
everything in one entity.
And these are common refactoring
that will happen
with your application.
And so the way to do this is
to think about this life
system that's always handling
transactions.
And it's actually a three-step
process.
In the first step, what you
want to do is change your
application, so that any time
that you write out an entity,
you're writing it out in the
new format or with the new
entity name, or with the
new properties, the new
constraints.
But at the same time, that every
time you do a read, you
first look for the new kind of
entity, and if you don't find
if, you look for the old kind.
And you deploy that.
And as soon as you deploy that,
your application will
slowly begin migrating data.
Any user that logs in and
touches their data, those
entities, those rows in
the DataStore will
begin to get migrated.
And now, actually, you're in
a perfectly happy state.
Your application will continue
to function.
There's a little bit of extra
read overhead for people as
they're migrating, but you now
have all the time in the world
to make the full migration
happen.
You're still serving
live traffic.
And now, depending on what you
want to do, you can either
say, we'll just leave
it like that.
But oftentimes that extra code
there is complexity you don't
want, and you might want
to get rid of that.
And so what you do is then
you run a, what we call a
MapReduce, which essentially
iterate over all the entities
of the old kind in
the DataStore.
And you just touch each one.
You can do that in
ApplicationLogic.
And as soon as you touch each
one, it gets migrated to the
new structure.
And you can take an hour
to do that, a day, you
take weeks or months--
really, however long it takes.
And once everything's been
migrated, then you go back
into your application and remove
that extra code in the
read handler.
And your apps migrated.
And many developers have many
of these migrations in place
at once, they might introduce
a few migrations
incrementally, and then maybe
once a quarter do a clean up
and get rid of some
of the code.
It's not the case that you have
to migrate everything in
a short window.
Think about doing things
live in real time.
MANDY WAITE: Wow.
OK.
That's cool. you have
one for me?
FRED SAUER: Yes.
All right, here's a developer
who is a little bit conscious
about the bill at the
end of the day.
He says, each day I fight
to really save every
penny on App Engine--
MANDY WAITE: We all.
FRED SAUER: We all do.
How could you help us
better profile our
applications, Appstats--
it's something you actually
mentioned--
he thinks is a little
bit hard to use.
And what's the best way to
tune your application?
MANDY WAITE: An interesting
question, OK.
So, yeah, we mentioned
Appstats earlier.
I think we've plenty discussed
it before.
We think the Appstats is
probably the way to go.
It's built into the platform
already, no
external tool is needed.
So, it's there really to go.
It would only profile
your own PCs.
It won't tell you where all of
the hot spots that need to be
cleared up, but it will
definitely give you a really
good indication about what your
application is spending
its time doing, particularly
in terms of RPC calls--
calls of the DataStore that
includes as well.
It's very easy to get up
and running as well.
So we're not sure if it's
difficult for you to actually
get up and running, and using
it, or if it's difficult for
you to actually get anything
meaningful from it.
But generally, it's fairly easy
for both Java and Python
to get up and running
with Appstats.
To get access to the console--
they provide a custom console
you can have access to, which
can actually include your
basic admin console.
Once you have that available to
you, you can look at your
own PCs, you can look at each
one of your requests, open up
the request and then drill down
into the request to see
where you're spending
your time.
And even then for Python--
I'm not sure if this is
available for Java, but with
Python you can actually look
at the code that actually
generated RPC call.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, in Python
you have stock
traces, that's right.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly, yeah, so
with Python you can actually
try showing to where the code
is-- and it's actually called
longer RPC calls-- and actually
modify them, redeploy
the application, see what
result you got.
So that's really cool.
So I think we recommend using
Appstats, definitely for RPCs.
I'm not really familiar with
any other profilers for App
Engine, although I did briefly,
the Khan Academy
actually produced a profiler.
Ben Kamens' Maven.
So hopefully worth
looking into.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, check
out Ben Kamens' blog.
He does have a Python profiler
with some nice UI widgets that
tell you about the loading
performance of your site.
To finish up on the Appstats,
I think, what some of our
users sometimes run into is
they feel like all the
information that Appstats
provide is really
overwhelming.
And it's good maybe to
take a step back.
And one of the things that
Appstats provides that I
really enjoy looking at is
there's these timeline graphs
that give you a breakdown
of the RPCs visually.
And 99% of the time when I'm
using Appstats, I only look at
the graphs.
There's a whole page though of
stack traces and debugging
information, and data that's
been sent back and forth.
Almost everything related
to performance of your
application you can find just
by looking at the graph.
You can see whether you have
DataStore reads that are
staircased all sequentially
behind one another, whether
they're happening in parallel.
You can see that you're making
them in cache call and then a
DataStore call, which
tells you there's a
in cache miss, right?
MANDY WAITE: Right.
FRED SAUER: So really just
getting comfortable with those
graphs, I think, will provide
most of value
with very little effort.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Would you recommend it for
running on production as well?
FRED SAUER: I do, but
depending on the
traffic of your site.
if you only have a few requests
per second, then,
yeah, sure, run it.
If you're doing a lot of
traffic, what we recommend is
that you either deploy another
version in production that you
hit, so you can say version
dot your app ID dot
[INAUDIBLE] dot com and
access that directly.
And that way you don't have
all the data from all the
requests from all your users
piling on top of each other,
but you can very carefully just
poke at your application,
say, I'm going to do this one
request here and then I want
to see the Appstats profile.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
FRED SAUER: We've even had
people with mobile clients.
They'll have a couple users
that report performance
problems, and they'll change
their application to send down
a ping to those users, and say,
OK, this mobile client
should connect to a different
backend name.
And then those users are
isolated on their own version,
where you can do diagnostics,
maybe you can enable some
traces, you can enable
Appstats.
And then, when everything's all
[INAUDIBLE], your tell the
clients to go back to the
original version.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: So, yeah, a lot of
ways to utilize that tool.
MANDY WAITE: All right,
definitely, OK.
Well, that's good.
Hopefully, that answered
the question.
So one for you.
FRED SAUER: OK.
MANDY WAITE: Any suggestions
on how to simply move data
from the live server
to development
server, and visa versa?
FRED SAUER: Sure.
We have in the App Engine admin
console there's a data
store backup feature, and it
allows you to create a
snapshot of your database.
And those snapshots can be
placed into your Google Cloud
Storage, so it's just a very
large file that you can then
download, you can store
it offline.
But you can also restore that
back up to another app ID.
And you can select actually
which kinds get backed up.
So that's a great way to copy
data between instances.
If you have like production and
QA environment, and you
need to get another
snapshot of data.
It's pretty common.
Or if you have been working
really hard for months in the
development server, and you have
all this configuration
data, maybe you want to just
take those kinds, grab a
backup of that, and restore
that, play that back
essentially on onto the
production server.
MANDY WAITE: Well, sounds easy.
OK.
FRED SAUER: Yeah?
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Excellent.
FRED SAUER: OK, for you.
let's see.
I need a testing strategy for
App Engine applications as the
SDK doesn't implement all the
services exactly the way that
the production environment does,
do you have any insight
about how to test your
applications taking into
account some of those
differences?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so I guess
testing, there's a lot of ways
to do testing, there's a lot of
levels you can do testing--
you can do unit testing,
functional testing,
integration testing.
Development testing is pretty
important of App Engine, you
really probably don't want to
deploy an untested version of
an application and replace the
current version that's working
really well with one that's not
been tested, particularly
extensively.
So, as always, when testing in
the development environment,
it's probably important to mock
services that you can't
actually access directly.
FRED SAUER: Sure.
MANDY WAITE: So in this case, if
there are any shortfalls in
what the development server
offers and what App Engine
offers itself, then you probably
want to mock that.
FRED SAUER: OK.
MANDY WAITE: So that would be
the same with accessing
another API that you don't
want to access from
development.
You may just mock that service
up, so you can actually get
reasonable results from making
course of that service.
Then you'd probably do the same
with App Engine as well
if any App Engine services
are missing.
And beyond that, really there's
lots of different
options for testing.
Once you've deployed the
application, you may, as
Fred's already mentioned, you
may deploy a different app
version, and then you may
use traffic splitting.
So App Engine has this feature
of traffic splitting, that
allows you to incrementally
direct traffic towards new
versions of your app.
So you can actually test it in
isolation to a degree, You're
pushing a small amount of
traffic to it initially, and
then slowly migrating all of
the traffic over as you get
more confident in the
application's performance.
And again also that other
kind of testing,
low testing and suchlike.
You don't really want to do load
testing on a production
applications.
You would probably need to build
a different version of
your application, then to pull
it out, and undo your testing
on that particular version
of your application.
You're also likely to need data
as well, so you need to
probably have a representative
set of sample data that you
can deploy your application.
If you have an empty DataStore,
it's not really
going to give you the exactly
same kind of results that your
production application would
do, so you probably want to
divine a set of data that you
can actually populate into
your application initially
to do the testing mode.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
Those are very, very,
very good points.
The one thing that bites people
a lot of times when
they're testing in a different
application ID, or even on the
production application before
they launch is people will not
use representative workloads.
MANDY WAITE: Right.
FRED SAUER: So they'll instead
of creating say 1,000 unique
accounts, which is sometimes
tricky to do, they'll say, OK,
we'll take 10 accounts and we'll
have each one log in 100
times running concurrently.
And those access patterns
actually change the way the
data is utilizing, and you don't
get very representative
results there.
So you already talked about
making sure that you have some
good sample data there, making
sure you have good
representative requests,
and users logging in.
It's just as important.
In any case, as much as you
can take the production
environment that you expect and
replicate it, the closer
you get, the closer
your results are
going to match, obviously.
MANDY WAITE: OK, OK.
So you can use tools like
Selenium and JMeter, those
kind of things for
low testing.
FRED SAUER: Absolutely.
MANDY WAITE: The same kind of
tools you would use for any
kind of workload web application
to generate tests.
And they generate representative
workloads,
believe me.
FRED SAUER: They do.
Just watch out that you're not
testing from one machine that
just doesn't have a big enough
network connection.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so don't talk
to me about client side,
because if your client can't
handle the load, you're never
going to actually load
on the server the way
you think you are.
So you need to make sure you can
actually generate the load
correctly, you're not falling
over lack of client resources
as well when you're testing.
FRED SAUER: I guess you can
always get a few instances on
Compute Engine--
MANDY WAITE: Ah.
FRED SAUER: There's some
capacity there.
MANDY WAITE: That's
interesting there.
Let's go there.
FRED SAUER: Nice big
pipe of data.
Let's see, where did
we leave off?
It's your turn.
MANDY WAITE: I've got
one for you, yeah.
Could you provide us with
state-of-the-art database
model designs?
OK, that's a big ask.
Things like CRM database model,
a bookshelf, an eBay
kind of application.
FRED SAUER: OK, it sounds to me
like the person asking the
question is looking for sample
model, sample applications.
And I hear the question behind
the question, which is how do
I go about modeling an
e-commerce site, a CRM site in
this non-relational,
NoSQL world.
I want to build an application
that can handle tremendous
scale, but you've swapped
the tools out from me.
I'm used to doing development on
a SQL database, relational,
I know how that works, but I
know that that doesn't scale.
So help me switch.
MANDY WAITE: Right.
FRED SAUER: I think it's
difficult to come up with
samples that fit every
single vertical.
But there are some general
things that we can say about
the way you do data modeling.
And really it's sort of changing
some of your habits
and some of the things that you
were taught maybe from the
beginning about working with
relational databases.
So one of the first tenets
when you're building a
relational database model is
everything needs to be
normalized.
No data duplicated.
It's typical in an order entry
system to have 5, 6,7, 10, 12
different tables, that every
time you want to do a query
and out what the orders are,
you have to join all these
tables at run time and
select your results.
So you might have a table that
has items in it, and it has
item description, item price,
and some other information;
then you have an order lines,
which connects to an header,
you have order line details,
it goes on and on.
And this is a really good way
of allowing you at run time
the flexibility to really join
any amount of data with any
amount of data, which
is what relational
databases were built for.
But in a very scalable world,
what you want is actually that
if you and I both make a request
to our website and
we're both interacting with the
service, what we want is
for your queries and my queries
to essentially be able
to be handled by different parts
of the infrastructure.
it's a distributed platform.
And the way to do that
is to isolate your
data from my data.
And that means what we don't
want is for if I'm pulling up
a list of my orders and you're
pulling up a list of your
orders, we don't want to both be
going to the same table and
running into each other.
We also don't want to take
a lot of time at run time
collecting the data.
In a distributed system, what
you like to do is amortize the
cost spread out the cost
and do that the
cost at right time.
So when we write the data
how we might do some
deduplication, so what you would
call denormalization.
So it's quite common in App
Engine apps for entities to
have properties with
string values.
So rather than have an item key
on your item details page,
you would actually have the
actual item code or the actual
description.
If you're putting together,
let's say, countries.
You have a client that
stores addresses
and you need countries.
In App Engine you would actually
just put the country
code, or even the full country
name in every single entity.
And you should resist the urge
to say, oh, I don't want the
duplication of data,
I don't want to pay
for the extra storage.
What you're really doing is
you're separating your data
and my data, and making it very
efficient to handle very
large number of requests.
There's more best practices,
but the first one that you
want to think about
is denormalization
is not a bad thing.
That's actually something you
should really just embrace.
And just pick two users and
imagine that they're both
doing the same thing in
your application.
How can you make it so that
the entities that you're
touching and the entities that
I'm touching are different,
because as soon as they're
separate from each other, then
the Google App Engine
infrastructure, the DataStore,
can put those entities on
different physical hardware,
different machines.
And now we can have a
third user, a fourth
user, a fifth user.
We can have 100,000 users, it
really doesn't matter how big
we scale up, because each user
is accessing a different part
of the system.
MANDY WAITE: Wow.
FRED SAUER: So there's a lot to
grasp if you're coming from
a SQL environment, but once you
play around with it for a
while, it's really freeing to
say, I really don't care how
many users show up on my
doorstep tomorrow, I can
handle 1,000 users, a million
users, a billion users.
It's really independent
of scale.
And that's what the App Engine
DataStore provides is
performance that's independent
of the amount
of data that's stored.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
Makes sense.
It's really good advice.
FRED SAUER: All right,
so, sorry for
the long answer there.
MANDY WAITE: No, I think it's
the kind of question that
deserves a long answer.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, it's a common
question, so it's fair
to spend a little
bit of time--
MANDY WAITE: A lot of people
moving from the old
traditional relational
database to
the NoSQL type one.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
And we should say, is if you do
want a relational system,
you have a limited
number of users.
You're building a corporate
application.
You only know your need for
the existing performance.
You can use Google Cloud SQL--
it's MySQL database,
runs in the Cloud,
managed for you, no headaches.
And you get all the traditional
kind of
performance trade offs
and benefits.
It's still an option.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
FRED SAUER: All right, next
question for you.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: Any optimization
recommendations for e-commerce
website with two million visits
per month, running on
App Engine Python.
MANDY WAITE: Well, OK,
how long have we got?
Optimization recommendation--
I guess what we want to optimize
for is probably
important thing here.
Do we want to for performance,
for load, for latency?
The cost-- and cost is an
important consideration, when
it comes to Cloud applications
as well balances cost and
performances.
Massively important.
So I think what I'm going to
step back on this one a little
bit and say, the best thing to
do is to read the resources
that are available in
the documentation.
So we have a couple of really,
really good pages on the App
Engine documentation site.
One is called Managing
resources--
FRED SAUER: Yes, my
favorite one.
MANDY WAITE: That's Fred's
Whenever I ask him a question,
he has have you
read managing resources?
So I go off and read managing
resources, and
I'll find the answer.
So managing resources
is great.
It tells you have to manage
your instances, manage
bandwidth, manage concurrency
and those kind of things.
And so that is an excellent
resource.
There's also a
performance-related resource
on the same site.
I think they're in the same
section, probably one leads
into the other.
And I will give you hints
on performance.
Often optimization and
performance are kind of
related, very married together
in a lot of ways, so you can
take those tips as one
big set of tips.
And you'll fine really good,
good information about how to
optimize your application.
If it's about cost again, I
think also managing resources
also talks about how to look at
your quotas and things like
an where you're incurring
your costs.
And also that becoming back
to Appstats So Appstats is
another really good essential
tool for looking at the way
you're spending your time
in your application.
So if you're concerned about
latency, having taken too long
to respond, so you go and use
this, then you can do some
analysis with Appstats to find
that way you're spending time,
and maybe tune your application
to spend less time
doing those RPCs.
FRED SAUER: OK.
MANDY WAITE: Does
it seem good?
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
I love the managing
resources article.
If you just do a web search
for App Engine managing
resources, you'd probably hit
that article in our Docs.
And think of it as
a checklist.
It doesn't tell you exactly of
everything to do, but it's a
checklist--
think about this, think about
this-- and you go through each
one and you know your
replication best.
I.e. can tune it.
If you just want the what's
the one thing I need to do
that I may not be doing
that's going to give
me the biggest benefit?
I say, turn on Memcache.
And some of you can
get that for free.
If you're using in Python the
NDBAPI, or in Java, if you're
using Objective, which is a
third party [INAUDIBLE]
layer, they both have
Memcache built in.
So any time you write or read
from the DataStore, it's
checking Memcache.
That can save you a lot of
DataStore operations, and it
won't cost you a single
line of code.
MANDY WAITE: Wow, fantastic.
So use Memcache.
FRED SAUER: Use Memcache.
If you're not using Memcache,
use Memcache.
MANDY WAITE: I was about to
suggest you use Mamcache.
OK, so I've got one for you.
Oh, another performance.
So what is the performance
difference between GAE Python,
GAE Java, and GAE Go?
There are three different
run times.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Fair question.
This is actually one that
comes up a lot.
It's a question that I tried
first not answer, and then I'm
happy to give an answer.
But I'd like to start out
and say there are subtle
differences between the three
different runtime
environments.
Python, if you write any
application in Python versus
Java, versus Go, there are some
things that work better
in one language versus
another.
What's probably much more
important for your
application.
For your service that you
are running is what your
developers know and where
they're going to be
productive.
So if you have a Python shop,
everyone knows Python really
well, and there's one or two
guys that know a little bit of
Java; even if Java were slightly
better for your
application, you're going to
be much more productive
building in Python.
So you should do that.
And the same goes the
other way around.
Having said that, if all things
were equal, if you
hadn't hired any development
staff yet, or you could pick
any language, or you just want
to learn something new--
there are some trade
offs to make.
And maybe you should look at the
complexity of the product
that you're building and how
long it's going to last.
Python is a scripting language,
tends to be a little
bit more productive for people
prototyping, iterating in
small teams, working together,
let's you be very agile-- you
can do things very quickly.
If on the other hand, you're
building a product, and you
have a very large development
team, or a very complex code
base, you're doing a lot of
refactoring and you could use
some help from tools that can
refactor code, do static
analysis; then Java is probably
the language that's
more productive.
And if you wanted to do
something that's really
performance sensitive, you want
to build with the stuff
that Googlers are building on,
I would seriously check out
the Go runtime.
There are some really pleasing
results there.
Having said that, that's an
experimental runtime still, so
if you're building a production
app right now,
probably Java or Python.
And pick the one you'll
be in productive.
MANDY WAITE: So retraining your
Java developers, so you
[INAUDIBLE]
in Go is probably not the best
way to get performance?
FRED SAUER: Unless that's
what motivates them.
For some people a new language
is the thing that wakes them
up in the morning, and more
so than a cup of coffee.
For other people it's being able
to be productive and hit
the ground running.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent.
OK.
Well, good advice.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Let's shoot one back
at you here.
Can I pre-populate
the DataStore?
Is there a front end to add,
remove, or update entries in
the DataStore.
MANDY WAITE: OK, so now I'm
going to punt this one a
little bit, because we discussed
this one yesterday,
and we talked about some things
and some articles that
have been published about
doing this very thing.
So I'd like to actually talk
to you about that.
I'll bounce the question back
to you and ask what you feel
is the best way to
pre-populate.
FRED SAUER: So, I think the
answer depends a little bit.
If you have some data on your
client, like on your desktop,
maybe there's some legacy data
that you need to import, some
configuration data that you want
to do programmatically,
the development server of or
the SDK does have a little
tool for uploading data.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: That works fine for
small scale, and that's a
tool that's been around
for a long time.
Probably what you want to do
if you're doing anything
larger than trivial operations
is just create a Cloud
Endpoints application
version of your app.
It doesn't mean you have to
build your entire service
around it, but maybe this is an
administrative gateway, or
this is a way that a mobile
clients upload data to your
application.
Cloud Endpoints is a great easy
way to create an API and
will automatically generate
client libraries for Android,
for iOS, for HTML5; and from
any of those three clients,
you can make your calls
to the server side.
If you're doing Python, a
colleague of ours, Danny
Hermes has a pretty cool project
called Cloud Endpoints
Proto DataStore.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: Or maybe it's
Endpoints Proto DataStore.
But it's an application, where
you essentially define your
Python DataStore models, and
then you just swap up the
class name that you're
inheriting from, and then all
your classes magically turn
into Cloud Endpoints.
And so you can make calls like
insert entities into the
DataStore, remove them,
do queries.
All really easy.
So that's probably the
way that I would go.
And then there's maybe one more
trick up your sleeve, the
SDK has a thing called
a Remote_API--
Remote underscore API.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: And it's a way for
the development server to
essentially proxy its DataStore
and then cache
request to the production
environment.
So what you do is you deploy a
special version of your app
with just like a one line config
flag, this is enabled
Remote_API.
And then you can run your code
locally as if you're connected
to the DataStore, but
everything's been proxy'd to
the Cloud for you.
So that's another
neat trick for
migrating data in the Cloud.
Or it's a great way to do
debugging, you connect to your
production or staging
environment, and you can
interact with it, while you're
in a Python console, you have
your real data models,
but you're looking
at your real data.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent.
OK.
I would not have been able to
come up with that answer.
So I'll let you ask me another
one now, because I think I
have more questions for you
than you have for me.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Let's see, startup times for my
App Engine Java are pretty
high for my applications,
around 30 seconds--
yeah, that is actually
pretty high and
Java apps in general--
even with reserved instances
that we feel are
underutilized, we're still
getting warm-up requests.
Any advice?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so I think,
again, this is something that
is going to be covered quite
extensively in Google I/O. We
have a talk, Matt Stephenson is
going to be giving a talk
on autoscaling Java.
So that talk is likely to
cover much of that.
And Matt Stephenson also with
one of our other guys from
Cloud Solutions, Wally Yau, he
wrote an article that was
published on the, again, the
App Engine Developers
documentation site for managing
optimization of
startup Spring applications.
And often we find that it's
Spring applications that
really take the longest
time to start.
There's a lot of libraries
involved, there's a lot of
scanning of classes and
suchlike that goes one
automatically with Spring
when it starts up.
And that can lead to quite
long low times.
As I suspect, this is probably
likely to be a Spring issue.
At the same time, there's also
the possibility to go loading
libraries that you may
not need immediately.
And you may want to actually
look at lazy loading those--
loading them in the background--
as opposed to
actually loading them as
you're instant starts.
Anything that you can do to
minimize the amount of time it
takes to start the application
is good.
And really, I think, that's
the key to handling things
like a startup requests, things
that will cause a new
instance to start.
It's basically just to minimize
the time it takes to
load your application
initially.
Only load what you need,
lazy load everything.
Don't load things you
don't need to load.
And also make sure if you're
using Spring that you follow
the advice in the Google
[INAUDIBLE]
and in that particular document
on the website.
That will minimize
your setup times.
And you won't be so worried
about startup requests then.
You can actually loading a new
instance, because that one
takes that long to do.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
All very good advice.
So, yeah, definitely check
out the Google I/O talk.
All the talks at I/O are going
to be recorded, so we can
check those out, talks
happening next week.
So it's a great resource.
MANDY WAITE: That's on
Wednesday, by the way.
Are they live streamed?
FRED SAUER: Some of
the talks are.
MANDY WAITE: Some of the talks
are live streamed, yeah.
FRED SAUER: I'm not sure if
Matt's talk is live streamed,
but you'll be able to catch
it pretty soon.
Maybe something-- just to say
a little bit more general
about App Engine Java,
especially these Spring apps
or applications that have these
big frameworks and long
loading times.
So one way to think about this
is the way that we've been
building application servers for
many years has been in an
environment where you
would spin up, say,
five application servers.
And these would be big
server that would
sit in a rack somewhere.
And they would take several
minutes to boot up, do all the
memory checks.
Machine would load up, it would
load the application
server software, than would
load the specific
applications.
And that whole process could
take 10-20 minutes sometimes.
But then those servers they
would run for weeks or months,
or however long they
needed to run.
And in that environment, what
you actually want to do is do
all the expense work upfront
when you're loading the
application, because you know
you're only going to that one
time, and then you're going to
have long-lived servers,
App Engine tries to really
fundamentally deal with
applications in a
different way.
When we want to scale up very
quickly to handle an increase
in traffic to your website, or
when we want to scale down,
because there's a little bit
less traffic coming in, we
really need the ability to
quickly spin up new instances
of your application, and then
spin them back down, at a
moment's notice.
And so App Engine is optimized
around apps that have a very
short startup time.
Ideally, it's hundreds of
milliseconds, maybe it's a few
seconds on the outset.
When you start getting into a
30-second time frame, that's
really a whole different
ballpark.
Now, if that's something you
want to do and you want to run
Spring applications, and you
say, I get a lot of benefit
out of that, and why can't
I just run an App Engine?
You can.
We actually, I think, a year
ago, we introduced some extra
knobs on the admin console,
specifically for these users.
What you'll need to do is go
into the admin console, make
sure you enable billing, because
that exposes all the
knobs that we have.
And then go into your
application settings.
And there's a couple of settings
around Min/Max Idle
Instances , Min/Max Pending
Request Latency.
And those allow you to tune the
cost performance of your
application.
So if you know you have long
loading requests and you just
need to keep in a few extra
instances around to make sure
you can handle those spikes,
even though you have long
instances, you can
actually crank up
the min idle instances.
MANDY WAITE: Right?
OK.
FRED SAUER: On the other hand,
if you're a fast starting app
and you're very cost sensitive,
there's ways to
turn it the other direction.
We recommend everyone start
out with the automatic
settings, but we do have some
special knobs for that.
And I'm sure Matt in his talk
will go into a lot more detail
than we did right here,
specifically around Java
application.
So that's definitely something
we care about, and we'll have
some advice for you.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
that's great.
[INAUDIBLE] give excellent
advice.
Oh, you've only got
one question.
FRED SAUER: I've got one.
MANDY WAITE: And
I've got four.
FRED SAUER: And then we have a
few more that came up in a
moderator since we looked
at these yesterday.
MANDY WAITE: Well, let me
ask you a question.
FRED SAUER: OK, go for it.
MANDY WAITE: How popular is
Google App Engine for Java?
Most examples seem to
be reaching for
Google App Engine Python.
FRED SAUER: I hope that's not
to the case as far as the
sample mismatch.
It is true that we launched
App Engine Python a year
before the Java runtime.
So in 2008 was Python, and then
in 2009 we added the Java
runtime, and later
we added Go.
So there may be just a little
bit of bias still left in the
system, because we originally
set out to just
have a Python runtime.
But I think things are
fairly evened out.
If you go to the Google Cloud
Platform user on GitHub,
there's many samples there.
There's Java and Python samples;
documentation, there
should be samples in
both languages.
I don't recall the exact kind
of popularity, but I thought
it was fairly even, maybe a
60/40 split or something like
that, with some percentage
are going to go.
But you shouldn't feel like Java
is an under appreciated
language in App Engine, it's
definitely not the case.
And if you look at the talks
at I/O, you'll then see our
focus on Java users and making
sure they as just as good
experience as Python.
So pick the language that's
good for you.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely,
Yeah, absolutely good advice.
Do you have one for me?
FRED SAUER: OK, I do.
So the App Engine documentation
is incomplete,
for example, the NDB Docs--
NDB is a Python library
for the DataStore--
remain minimal and really
document possible errors.
Anything you can
do about this?
Or are there other places
I should be looking?
MANDY WAITE: Well, I guess
really, the one of the
standard answers is to
go to Stack Overflow.
You're going to find
documentation, people talk
about things undocumented or
not so well documented,
providing examples and suchlike
on Stack Overflow.
Pretty much everything anybody's
tried to do is going
to be documented on
Stack Overflow.
Things that have worked, things
that haven't worked--
so you can probably find
good answers there.
If you want to contribute
information as well, Stack
Overflow is not just
for questions.
It's also for sharing
information as well.
So if you actually have some
useful information--
something you've written
about, something you've
documented--
you can share that on Stack
Overflow as well.
Definitely a good
place to put it.
And it also stops you from
being spread around
everywhere.
We could have multiple places
where people would go to find
different documentation.
So that kind of ad hoc
organization probably is the
best place in the
Stack Overflow.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, I think
of the App Engine core
documentation is kind
of the reference
material, the baseline.
Sometimes there's Javadocs or
Pydocs, two of the methods
that may help a little bit
further, but some of these,
like how do I use this
specifically, Stack Overflow
is a great place to go.
And we do sometimes, if we find
that there's a lot of
questions around a particular
are in Stack Overflow, we do
go in and update the
documentation, and maybe add
some clarification.
So that's definitely a
place to contribute.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
Excellent, OK, so a
question for you.
FRED SAUER: All right.
MANDY WAITE: OK, I'm going to
read this through first, so I
know what I'm asking.
I've developed an
application--
12 [INAUDIBLE].
But today I had difficulties
to setup the IT strategy
related to the maintenance
of the source code.
Taking into account the amount
of leases of Google App Engine
platform, do you have
any advice?
FRED SAUER: If I remember
right, I think you were
suggesting that the person who
asked this question, asked a
few more questions.
And I think you said, it look
like they were maybe running
Python 2.5.
Yeah, so App Engine has a
deprecation policy on all of
our production services--
I believe it's one year--
and that's our guaranteed to you
that we're not just going
to change APIs on you, that
when we bump up the next
version of the application, your
application is going to
continue working, the APIs are
going to behave the way that
they expected.
Having said that, there
are incremental
changes that we make.
Just like the Python
languages is--
Python 2.5 is not as common
any more, it's Python 2.7.
At some point you need
to make a switch.
It should certainly not
be a regular burden.
I have applications that I
deployed more than a year ago,
and they are still running
just fine.
That's the experience of
most of our users.
Usually what we find is that
developers are making changes
because they want to take
advantage of new APIs or new
capabilities that
we've launched.
There've been probably a couple
of cases, where we've
had a change in--
not a breaking API change, but
a new version of a capability
that we've made available--
and that's from Python
2.5 to 2.7.
There are some differences.
And Python 2.7 provides a lot of
great features that weren't
just possible in 2.5, like the
ability to handle concurrent
requests, there's many
language preferences.
We also had to change from the
Master/Slave DataStore to the
High Replication DataStore,
which has huge advantages.
The Master/Slave DataStore had
regular maintenance periods,
there are still a few
users on that.
But I believe the majority of
users are now on the High
Replication DataStore.
Just a much better experience.
When you commit your data, it
gets committed to multiple
data centers synchronously.
When a data center goes down,
you don't even notice it.
And that sort of improvement
is sometimes worth going
through the effort and making
sure that the way you're
executing queries is still
compatible with the new
version, but you have plenty of
time to make that change on
your schedule.
So what we find that developers
do is they use one
version of the SDK, they're
developing locally, they go
through a couple of releases
on their own.
And then there's a break, maybe
once a quarter or so,
they say you know what,
let's catch up
to the latest features.
Let's see what we
can incorporate
that we haven't yet.
And then they'll bump
up the version.
And so you should naturally
flow along with
the App Engine releases.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
It's important to also stress
what we mentioned earlier.
Experimental features are always
likely to change from
one release to another.
So if you are using an
experimental feature, you are
probably getting an enormous
benefit just
from using that feature.
But you may have to adjust your
code when we release a
new version, just to keep
up-to-speed with us.
Hopefully, that's not a big
impact, though-- not something
that causes huge--
FRED SAUER: No, it's generally a
polish around the edges when
it's in the experimental.
Or we're still trying to collect
feedback from the
community, find out new use
cases; Maybe there's ways that
we can improve the
API a little bit.
And so you've seen that, for
example, with the search API
that from the very early
days to now,
there's a couple of changes.
But generally things have just
gotten better, and all of our
users have been quite
happy with that.
MANDY WAITE: All right,
excellent, OK.
So we've got two
questions here.
You can ask me one
if you want.
FRED SAUER: OK, well I have a
couple here too I can ask you.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, I see,
yeah, we can do it.
You're putting me
on the spot now.
FRED SAUER: I am.
Let's see.
Please share tips on rate
limiting requests without
having to hit the DataStore.
Memcache-based counter could
work, but item expiry time is
a little bit unpredictable.
How would you go about rate
limiting individual users?
MANDY WAITE: Interesting,
I don't know.
That's probably the kind of
thing that I have not actually
run across yet.
So I'm going to punt that
one to you as well.
FRED SAUER: OK, well I think
the person here suggested a
really good place to
start, which is a
Memcache-based counter.
Memcache is using--
at least recently used--
an LRU-based cache.
And that means that the users
that are most heavily
accessing your application,
those Memcache keys are more
likely to actually
be in the cache.
And those that haven't been
around a while, they're
further down the list, and
those will expire.
So you sort of naturally get the
keys that you care about
most recent memory.
If you're looking at maybe
even more aggressive
throttling, where maybe you have
some abusive users, and
you really want to cap that
behavior down, you can take it
up a notch and do some
throttling within the instance.
So you could introduce a data
structure, a global static
variable, in your code, that for
each App Engine instance
keeps track of the hot users
or users recently seen, and
maybe throttles those
individually.
And then if there's
a miss there,
then you go to Memcache.
And what you're doing
is you're just
taking up another tier.
You have at the bottom you
have the DataStore, where
there's transactions
happening.
And there's this limit of one
transaction per second that
you want to deal with
per entity group.
Then Memcache, you can
go much faster.
And then in the Instance cache,
you can go even faster,
because you're just in memory.
There's no cross-network
call to be made.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: So, yeah, I think
Memcache is a great place to
get started and you have to use
Instance caching if you
need to there.
Swell.
Right, you had another
one, you said?
MANDY WAITE: I do,
indeed, yeah.
Last one-- last one
from the list.
We have a few more over there.
So for GAE Java, there are
detailed documentation for
low-level DataStore API.
However, fewer and incomplete
documentation for how to map
entity relationships
with JDO and JPA.
The data nucleus is detailed,
however, there's no easy way
to tell if GAE supports
a feature.
So, there's a question
in there somewhere.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, so the
question is really, I think,
around the giving to this the
full details and capabilities
of JDO and JPA on App Engine.
Maybe I should put this a
little bit in context.
When we launched the Java
runtime on App Engine, we
looked at the act of frameworks
and an abstraction
that people were using, JDO
and JPA were very popular.
And so we did a lot of work to
make sure that those were
properly supported
in App Engine.
We also felt like users really
benefited from SQL like
language, and so we launched
GQL, as a way of
accessing the DataStore.
And what we found over time,
actually, is that developers
after a little while feel much
more productive when they're
working much closer with low
level APIs of App Engine, or
some abstraction that sits on
top of those low level APIs.
So in the case of Python,
we had the
low-level Python DataStore.
We've now iterative on that
and we have NDB, the new
database, which is the way that
we wish we had written
the first time with Memcache
built-in, and just usability
is a lot better.
On the Java side, we've actually
had the community
step up and produce
an [INAUDIBLE]
framework called objectify.
And there's others out there.
There's a developer in Japan who
created something called
slim 3, it's another abstraction
layer for Java.
And they do a really good job of
obstructing the way of the
DataStore a little bit, but
still staying very close to
the native performance
characteristics doing things
the right way.
Objectify, I know, also
has Memcache built-in.
And it just lets you work
with POJOs-- so
plain old Java objects.
So you have a Java object with
a bunch properties--
getters and setters--
you can just take that object
and push it in the DataStore
and get it right back out.
And that feels a lot more
natural working in App Engine
than in JDO and JPA.
And so the way to look at those
technologies right now
is if you're a big JDO and JPA
fan, or you just use those in
your environment and you'd like
to, please continue to
use them, they are
there for you.
But if you're new to App
Engine or you're at all
unfamiliar about JDO and JPA,
by all means, use either the
low level APIs or something
like Objectify in Java,
because you'll just have a
much better experience.
And those were written from the
ground up for App Engine.
Whereas JDO and JPA
were written in a
world where SQLs came.
And it's a little bit
of an unnatural fit.
We got that square peg into the
round hole, but we had to
use the hammer a little bit,
and so the corners are a
little bit rounded off.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
I come from a Java EE
background, so I used to have
a very big hammer.
FRED SAUER: I'm just visualizing
the big hammer.
Let's see, a question
here for you.
At the rate at which you can
write the same entity group is
limited to one entity group of
write per second, and this
developer is writing,
it seems really low.
If you're imagining a Facebook
applications with 200,000
daily active users, which means
something like 20,000
concurrent users on peak.
So they're kind of
contrasting this.
They say, well, on the one hand
I have 20,000 concurrent
users all making requests at
the very same moment, and
you're telling me
one per second?
Where is the disconnect?
MANDY WAITE: I think here
depends on what your entity
group was actually developed
to represent and how
extensively you've modeled
it and the way you've
modeled your data.
If your entity group is really
specific to the particular
user that's making the call,
then you won't really have to
worry about it.
One write per second will
be perfectly adequate.
But if you kind of sprawled
it a bit, and the entity
intergroup touches multiple
users, then you're likely to
have some contention in
that entity group.
And so you have multiple users
banging away at the same time.
So really it's best practices of
modeling your entities that
will actually avoid that
kind of issue.
So if you have 20,000 concurrent
requests, they're
likely to be accessing 20,000
different entity groups.
You wouldn't have an issue.
FRED SAUER: And that
should be fine.
If you want to do two million
concurrent users on two
million different
entity groups,
that's absolutely fine.
MANDY WAITE: Absolutely.
FRED SAUER: So think about
entity groups as, for the most
part, your unit of
transactionality.
So If you need some data related
to a given user, like
a user and their achievements,
for example, and you have
those stored in three or four
different entities, you can
put them all in one entity
group, and then the App Engine
DataStore will make sure that
you can only have one
transaction in flight at a time
for that entity group.
So generally what we see is
that each user becomes an
entity group, or each order in
an order entry system, each
customer in a CRM system becomes
an entity group.
We actually also have--
we didn't have this initially,
but now we introduced this
again about a year ago--
something called cross-entity
group transactions, or XG
transactions.
And that allows you to transact
up to five different
entity groups in a single
transaction.
So it used to be the case that
before we had XG transactions,
there was a little bit of this
trade off between I want to
make my entity groups bigger,
because I want to do
transactions, but I need to make
them smaller to have the
right throughput.
And that was sometimes
a challenge.
There were in fact libraries
that sprung up to try to
figure out how to-- the classic
example is I've two
bank accounts.
I want to move $10 from this
bank account to that bank
account, I need to do that
within a transaction.
And if I deduct 10 here and
then add 10 there, and
something goes wrong in the
middle, the $10 had
disappeared.
Or if I add $10 first, and then
remove $10, I've created
$10 out of nothing.
MANDY WAITE: I like that one.
FRED SAUER: Well, let's
do that one.
With cross-entity group
transactions, that's no longer
a problem, you can actually
in a single
transaction make that change.
So really, I think, this is
all about just structuring
your data store in such a way
that you do no more than one
break per second.
Another classic way that
people run into this is
they'll do something like
they'll create a site counter.
They want to know how many
visitors came to the website.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
FRED SAUER: Favorite
example, right?
And do every time a user comes
onto the website, they
increment the counter.
And this is what you would do
in a SQL Database, you would
increment a particular row in
the DataStore and the problem
is only one person at a time
can update that one record,
because that one record is on
disc somewhere, and there's
some server responsible
for it.
And you can only touch
that record one
transaction at a time.
And that's really limiting
for the number of
things you can count.
And so typical strategy that
you use for the App Engine
DataStore, is to create
something called a charting
counter, charted counter,
where you partition the
counter into multiple
counters.
So instead of, saying, say, one
counter, you split it out
and say, OK, let's make
five counters or 50.
Some number, and it's
configurable.
And now every time someone
comes to the website, I'm
going to at random pick a number
from one to five, and
then I'm going to update
that counter.
So, let's say, it's counter
three this time, the next
visitor comes in, oh, it's
again, the counter three.
Oh no, it's counter two.
And you say, well, that's weird,
because now your total
patriot count is
split up around
five different counters.
But that's not a big deal,
because you can easily select
five numbers and add
them together.
This is a very easy task
for a computer to do.
But by doing so, you've just
increased the throughput of
your web counter fivefold.
If you need 50 transactions per
second, you go 50 fold,
plus a little bit buffer.
So maybe you go 60, or
something like that.
It's very easy to chart your
counter out as far
as you need to go.
MANDY WAITE: There's actually
examples on the
website, isn't there?
FRED SAUER: Yeah,
it's an article.
So with a little bit of data
modeling you can do as many
concurrent users as you like.
And, hopefully, you do a
lot more than 20,000.
But 20,00o is pretty awesome.
I wish my website had--
MANDY WAITE: 20,000 is pretty
very good, yeah.
Well, I guess the message here
really is avoid shared
meterable stay.
I love shared meterable
stay as a saying.
Every time you share,
state is meterable.
You're going to run into
problems with concurrently.
So just keep it isolated.
And--
FRED SAUER: If do that, you're
going to have a bad time.
MANDY WAITE: You're going
to have a bad time.
Absolutely.
FRED SAUER: Do you want
to ask me these ones?
MANDY WAITE: Definitely, yeah.
This one, I think everybody
is interested in.
This person is asking the
question, what are 10
different definitions
of the frontend
versus the backend instance?
And I'm still not very clear
what the difference is between
frontends and backends.
Is that something you can
explain to everybody?
FRED SAUER: Yeah, so, actually,
you mentioned this
in the introduction, sort
of the two different
notions of a backend.
You talked about mobile backends
for Cloud Endpoints.
And then App Engine has a
specific definition of what
the frontend is and what
the backend is.
And, frankly, other customers
have said that's confusing.
And we found it a little bit
limiting in what developers
want to do with their
applications.
And so if you have been actually
reading through the
release notes carefully, you'll
notice that we've
already started talking about
a new way of classifying
components in an application,
called servers.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to get rid of the
two special cases the frontends
that do things one
way, and the backends, who do
things slightly differently.
And we're just going to say, you
can have as many different
types of servers as you want.
You can call them frontends
and backends.
Maybe one of them is your mobile
API, and one is your
admin API, and the third one
is something experimental.
Maybe you have a component
that's text message
processing, another component
that's real time interactive
stuff, and the third
one that's reports.
Every application
is different.
But when you get beyond a
trivial application, you often
want to logically split your
application into pieces, or
you may want to deploy the
different pieces separately.
Like your mobile backend that's
handling all your
mobile requests, maybe you have
a new version for that.
And with this we'll allow you to
see separate traffic graphs
for each of your server
versions--
your logs will be
separated out.
So your mobile backend logs and
your static image logs can
be separate.
So all of that's coming.
Just check out the release
notes, you'll see that.
And just forgive us for calling
them frontends and
backends, we'll make
that go away.
You have an application, you
split it in logical pieces,
and we'll allow you to configure
the different pieces
the way you want, whether you
want different instance sizes,
different logs, et cetera.
MANDY WAITE: So things like
what if [INAUDIBLE] has
currently autoscaling, that
would just be a property of a
server instance-- of
a type of server.
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
So you say, if I have a mobile
backend, autoscaling on.
I have this batch backend, where
I'm only going to do
certain administrative tasks.
I actually only want one
instance of the server
running, and it's just going to
be crawling some database
or doing some background work.
And you can have variations
in between.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent, OK.
Sounds good.
FRED SAUER: So we're making it
easier and we're simplifying
the terminology.
MANDY WAITE: Fantastic.
Thank you.
So you did explain it.
FRED SAUER: I hope so.
All right, question here.
What are the best practices for
migrating from Python DB
to the Python NDBAPI?
MANDY WAITE: OK, so I've got
a confession to make here.
FRED SAUER: OK.
MANDY WAITE: I'm a Java girl.
I come from a Java background.
So I don't really deal with
a huge amount with NDB.
I've actually looked through
the documentation, it looks
really cool, but I wouldn't
know where to start.
FRED SAUER: OK, well, so, I
have been calling myself a
Java guy, but in the last year
and a half or so, I have to
confess, I've been becoming
somewhat of a Python fan.
And I've been taking my own
projects and migrating them.
So I think I can say maybe
a few words about this.
First thing is you don't have
to migrate all at ones.
If you have an application, you
have many different Python
classes, and you've models all
over the place, you can
actually migrate a class follow
the time, you can
migrate a model at a time, you
can intermix the two APIs.
And the good news is that along
the way you'll probably,
if you've done things around
Memcache caching, there's a
lot of code you can delete,
because NDB just
does things for you.
The syntax between the two is
a little bit different.
So one of the first things you
might do is maybe go around
hunting for there's a cheat
sheet I've seeing that has the
DB way and the NBD way.
And that in the beginning
is very good
for just like mapping.
Like, oh I need to change
this around and do this.
But you'll find that they're
very, very similar.
And like I said, just do one
model at a time, one class at
a time; test it, make
sure it works.
And then keep going.
And maybe what you do is you
start out with any new models
that you create, do them in
NDB, so you start to get
really familiar with it, and
then migrate your old stuff.
But like with any real-time
application, where you're
always serving requests, think
about ways of doing things
incrementally, rather than
in one big step.
I don't think there is really
anything, any other tips for
people migrating.
MANDY WAITE: What about people
getting started?
So like when you're starting out
developing an App Engine
application using Pythons, is it
immediately obvious in the
documentation suchlike when
you're developing with DB and
when you're developing
with NDB?
Is it easy to get pushed
on one path?
FRED SAUER: You can accidentally
flip between the
two-- both are in the left nav
of the documentation, but it's
very clear in your code, because
in one case you're
importing from Google App Engine
EXTDB; and the other
place you're doing NDB.
So there's no confusion there.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: But, yeah, I do
find, when I'm clicking around
the documentation, I sometimes
end up looking
in the wrong one.
You'll get through that.
MANDY WAITE: So I guess if
people are reading books on
App Engine development,
Python-based, they may be
looking at older examples that
use DB, and probably worth
spending some time, investing
some time to actually look at
the differences in how you would
do that in NDB, rather
than actually just writing up
the samples in the DB code.
FRED SAUER: Absolutely, yeah,
if you're building anything
new, you should only
be using NDB.
The author who wrote both
basically he rewrote it and
said this is how it should
have been done the first.
So I can see a future where DB
is either deprecated or tucked
away in the documentation
for very few to find.
And NDB is just the way
you should be writing
applications.
And we've actually just going
through a process with our
sample applications.
So if you look on again GitHub
on the Google Cloud Platform,
hopefully right now all
the samples have
been updated to NDB.
So if you want good samples of
best practices and how to do
that, definitely go to
our GitHub page.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent.
OK.
FRED SAUER: Let's see, we have
another question here.
What's the best strategy to
respond to requests that
probably take more than
60 to process?
MANDY WAITE: Was that part
of the question?
So make a backend process
to process the request.
That's the best thing to do.
You can do these things out
of band, or almost natural
request itself.
So the user makes a request.
You need to actually service
that request within 60
seconds, otherwise you'll hit a
deadline exceeded exception
in both Java and Python
runtimes.
That's the request timeout we
have that's always in place
for what we call frontend
instances currently.
There's no such limitation
in backend instances.
So what Fred said about moving
to the server model, if you
choose to use a standard
instance, so it's not using
autoscale, those things
won't apply.
It won't automatically hit
its request timeout.
So the best thing to do is if
you need to do heavy lifting,
then when working to answer a
user request you should find a
way to do that asynchronously
out of band from actually
responding to the user.
So long running task, let's say
user makes a request that
will result in generating 100
e-mails to different people.
What you need to do is return a
request back, respond to the
user pretty quickly; and
offline doing it in the
background--
the e-mail process using
a backend instance.
It doesn't need to be a backend
instance, you could
push it off the task queues, and
then you can start using
things like Compute Engine
and suchlike.
Compute Engine has the ability
to do pull requests using
using task queues.
So you can use Compute Engine
instances to service those
requests as well.
But yeah, basically take it
away from the frontend
instances and push it into a
background somewhere, using
the backend end process
or Compute Engine.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, task queue is
definitely the way to go.
The pull queues you mentioned
are great for working with
external systems, like doing
off App Engine work, like
Compute Engine, but you could
really do it on a server that
you have sitting in a rack in
your office if you have some
special processing that
you need to do.
And then push queues are a great
way of enqueing work
asynchronously.
And those requests come back to
your application as if it
were traffic, but its
internal traffic.
So App Engine will scale
up and down if
you create more requests.
And then you have a
10-minute deadline
instead of the 60-second.
So you can easily make those
long running URL fetch calls
or do more complex processing.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
FRED SAUER: All right, when a
user uploads a photo, like a
movie or an audio clip, how do
you store it so it can be
statically available to
your application?
So it looks like they'd rather
not have a dynamic request
handler, where they have to
handle the request and figure
out what [INAUDIBLE] to serve,
what file to serve.
But how do you make it available
statically, so the
user can always get
to it without
involving App Engine runtime?
MANDY WAITE: So correct me if
I'm wrong, but I guess you
would probably find a place
where you would actually store
this photographs, other images
and movies- that
kind of blob data.
And then you would make sure
that you declare that folder,
that directory to be a static
directory within the
declaration of the
application.
And that way all of that will
be pushed to the edge by our
edge servers.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, you could do
that for pre-defined content.
If you're doing dynamically
uploaded content though, you'd
probably do that through your
Google Cloud Storage.
MANDY WAITE: Yes, basically
storing in Google Cloud
Storage and then you can provide
a URL back to the user
that can actually access it
directly from Cloud Storage,
as opposed to going through
your App Engine instances.
FRED SAUER: Exactly, yeah.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, good point.
FRED SAUER: And, yeah, we have
a new Google Cloud Storage
Client Library that you can
find in the groups.
And it's basically a new library
for accessing Google
Cloud Storage very easily and
efficiently from App Engine.
So I'd probably use that
to get the files
into the Cloud Storage.
And then just like you
said, [INAUDIBLE]
the URLs directly to that.
MANDY WAITE: And it has the
additional benefit of not
actually hits in
your instances.
So you won't actually incur any
costs, because you'll be
serving that data directly from
Google Cloud Storage.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, you're just
paying for bandwidth, not CPU.
Yeah.
If I built my start up on App
Engine, will Google help me
with publicity?
MANDY WAITE: Well, I guess,
it depends how
successful you are.
FRED SAUER: Depends on how
cool an idea you have.
You've probably seen a number of
customers with interesting
stories on the App
Engine blog.
I think if you came to
us with a really cool
story, just reach out.
We love to tell these stories
and share them with our users.
So that's probably--
yeah.
MANDY WAITE: Tell us about
your application.
Tell us about all the of the
cool and interesting things
you're doing and we can
look into it for you.
FRED SAUER: And also you and
I both do presentations.
We often share partner stories
and things like that.
So, definitely, tell
us about them.
We'd love to feature them.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
FRED SAUER: Well, that was the
last question of our list.
Looks like we've got to pretty
much everything.
There is a couple that we
skipped over due to time.
I want to thank all the viewers
for visiting today.
Send us more questions if
you really like this.
Let us know, because we can
definitely do it again.
I think it was fun answering
questions.
Thank you, Mandy, for doing the
presentation at the beginning.
It was very helpful.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you, Fred.
And don't forget Google
I/O next week.
Follow it as live if you
possibly can, if the sessions
you are interested in are
actually being streamed live.
If not, follow them on
YouTube afterwards or
the Google I/O sites.
The links, as I say, are
in the the YouTube
video of this recording.
And also, if you can,
participate
in Google I/O Extended.
So that's really one way of
getting involved in Google I/O
outside of event itself.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you so much.
Cheers.
Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]